[Musique]
mon pote dit ça sur plein trip là j'ai
l'impression d'avoir déjà vécu cette
journée déjà vu ouais t'es mort est
ajournée à recommencer c'est ça ouais je
pense que je peux t'aider
j'ai été tuées en soi j'étais coincé
dans la même journée que je revivais
encore et encore elle doit commencer dès
que quelqu'un qui portait un masque
m'assassiner le soir de mon anniversaire
j'ai fini par découvrir que c'était ma
coloc loric j'ai balancé cette malade
par la tête et je vais tuer ce qui m'a
fait sortir de la boucle et aujourd'hui
je vis ma vie mais en mieux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai non salut terville j'étais
plié ton pantalon c'est pas fred a
réussi à tirer son coup quoi mais
j'hallucine
on est lundi 18 encore entrerait sur
pointes hématome l'a cru que j'allais
briser le cycle mais ça a commencé
c'est pas vrai tout a changé cette fois
il est où ce fils et si tu remets pas
les compteurs à zéro ils seront morts
pour toujours c'est ça donc il va
falloir que je me fasse tuer encore et
encore pour tous vous serez tu pourrais
trouver une solution pourra mettre toi
même les compteurs à zéro
génial ton idée
[Musique]
si j'arrête pas le tueur va y avoir
d'autres victimes là on n'a pas le droit
de se planter
[Musique]
comprendre au sens propre salut été
réveillés
[Musique]
c'est voir ce que tu as dans le portrait
c'est l'état d'urgence la tri personnes
voudra rejoindre cap avec cette
malédiction
[Musique]